we just got our ass totally kicked
we couldn't do diddly poo offensively we
couldn't make a first down we couldn't
run the ball we didn't try to run the
ball we couldn't complete a pass we
sucked the second half we sucked we
couldn't stop the run every time they
got the ball they went down and got
points we got our ass totally kicked in
the second half that's what it boiled
down to it was a horse performance in
the second half
i'm totally embarrassed and totally
ashamed
former saints and colt's head coach jim
moore you ever want to get down an
interesting rabbit hole on youtube look
up some jim mora rants because
let me tell you he
he he he he can paint uh with some
interesting colors that's for damn sure
no i mean that's one of my favorite
clips of all time i mean that's just
amazing he's awesome i love it i mean
it's amazing how you know coaches really
don't do that anymore it's become more
of a little bit of a i don't know
corporation
head coach uh this day and age as
compared now no no because of social
media because they now understand you
know in the old days sometimes you you
took you wouldn't see those clips or you
kind of you were aware it was going to
be but now it's instantaneous it's
everywhere and fans can react to it
immediately by responding to that video
that shows up on twitter i think they're
much more conscious of it now because
it's all instantaneous it's out there
and people can criticize it in real time
yeah okay maybe that that certainly is a
big part of it i yeah but i i yeah i
mean just it seems like i just feel like
you know i don't care if social media
was around or not okay i think if he was
coaching this jim moore was coaching
this day and age and mike ditka was
coaching right now and bill parcells
they'd say whatever the hell they'd want
to say on a daily basis no matter what
and we'd get better i just feel like
it's kind of a different animal that's
all i was saying it it may be that guys
with those personalities don't have jobs
now for that very reason yeah maybe
you're right you're right right all
right topic of today's draft team or
player about which we are oddly
pessimistic this is the b side to
yesterday's draft about players and
teams about which we are oddly
optimistic and uh i'm pessimistic about
winning the coin toss i i hope so i mean
i'm gonna go heads here because i don't
think she's gonna go tails three days in
a row i think this i think you're over
thinking yeah nope i'm not i'm thinking
just right thank you very much captain
okay
all right where do i start here okay all
right you know i'm gonna get people
riled up right off the bat okay but yeah
i mean i think you're gonna agree with
this a little bit and i'm not saying the
world's gonna fall out here but i'm
oddly pessimistic about drew brees okay
in the new orleans saints i mean yes
they were 13-3 last year and awesome and
did a lot of great things and i don't
think they're going to fall off the
earth this year i mean i don't think
it's gonna be like that where they're
gonna go six and ten but you know as you
and i have talked about a lot there was
things to be worried about about drew
brees in his play towards the end of the
year i mean come on he had three games
last year where he threw for less than
180 yards and in those games it was six
touchdowns three interceptions he became
kind of charlie check down last year
intended air yards right in the nfl he
was 28th in football last year tied with
eli manning you know longest completions
down down down the field he was 31st you
know worse than blake bortles and brock
osweiler last year let alone we saw it
with our own two eyes that it didn't
look quite as crisp as years past now i
think they can win but yeah there is
some pessimist pessimism
yes did i say that right yes in my brain
if you say it enough times if you say it
sometimes enough different ways thank
you it's guaranteed eventually one of
them will it's not guaranteed with me
that's not that's a false statement
i i i agree with you on drew brees and
that was on my list as well
because we began to see the signs last
year and what taysom hill showing up on
multiple appearances to throw the deep
ball right and what the first snap the
play that they hand picked in the
divisional round game against the
philadelphia eagles we had a clip of it
earlier right throw the ball down the
field to ted again what happens drew
brees didn't put enough zip on it they
knew for days or possibly for the two
full weeks of their buy that that's what
they were going to do to start that game
and he didn't put enough under it
because he's if he's 40 now look not
everybody is going to be tom brady and
still do everything he was able to do
well beyond his 40th birthday for some
of these guys father tom is going to
catch up sooner there have not been many
quarterbacks in the history of the nfl
they've continued to play at a high
level beyond their 40th birthday and i
think that uh there's reason for your
pessimism you're throwing the fact that
the saints have had why am i propping up
your response two horrible heart
stomping outcomes to the post season
minneapolis miracle the rams saints nfc
championship game debacle go back to
zero and zero it's not going to be easy
to do if they do it it's going to be one
of the best coaching jobs that sean
payton will have ever put in all right
i'm going to stay
in the conference i'm going to stay in
that game that rams saints
nfc championship game the la rams parlay
that into a super bowl birth they score
only three points in the super bowl and
yeah there's just this sense that every
team that makes to the super bowl
they're going to get back the next year
and the patriots tend to reinforce that
notion but i don't
think the rams are going to have quite
as easy of a time this year as they did
last year for a variety of reasons from
todd gurley's injury yeah and i know
they don't like to talk about it but
it's a thing he's not a workhorse
anymore and they're going to have to
rely on other aspects of their offense
that puts more pressure on coach sean
mcvay puts more pressure on quarterback
jared goff who is yet to get his
long-term contract even though the guy
taken one spot after him in the 2016
draft carson wentz has gotten his payday
i think that defense could still be very
good but if the offense takes a dip it's
more pressure on the defense the
seahawks i think will be every bit of uh
as good as they were last year the 49ers
may be better the conference is more
challenging everybody's going to be
coming after the rams this year i just i
i i'm not going to say they're not going
to make the playoffs i'm not going to be
surprised if they don't make the
playoffs and it's going to be hard for
them very hard for them to get back to
the super bowl it's going to be hard
enough for them just to win their
division again yeah i mean you know
there's lots of things to like about
their team certainly i'm with you though
i think they're on that playoff bubble
right on the edge there i'm certainly
not gonna pick them to be the number one
or number two seed when i have to make
those type of predictions here in the
preseason at some point uh yeah there's
just a lot we got to see i mean again
you know the way golf played down the
stretch you know there was a lot of
underwhelming games uh it showed when
they didn't have gurley that they
couldn't just depend on him to go out
and win football games you know
showed some some not so great play and
some bad weather moments right i mean
the two games last year he played in
denver it was cold gosh there was not
good it was not a good passing
performance there went to chicago it was
cold not a good day so it's not only
golf too it's the offense mcveigh's got
to reinvent himself to a degree i hear
you and you know just normal human
emotions you would think there'd be a
letdown with the saints and rams it's
hard to pick these kind of drafts
because pessimism goes along with
somebody that was had a great year last
year too so it's a narrow field but i'm
with you there they were on my shoulder
and it's hard and it's hard to and you
want it you want to get on somebody's
long list of enemies oh you start
picking a great team and saying i know
i'm sorry sorry you're not going to be
great this year that's the last thing
the fans of those teams want to hear all
right so let's find
another being
to alienate him next i know i almost
didn't want to pick the drew brees just
because i didn't want to hear it all day
later on i'm going to go with derek
henry and the tennessee titans you know
specifically derek henry right now am i
oddly uh pessimistic yes i am i mean you
know to be captain obvious he's dealing
with a calf injury okay and he's a
running back and he uses his legs to run
and the calf muscle is very important
there to run so that for one concerns me
okay so that's where i'm pessimistic
about that number two hey the past game
it's unproven to this point marcus
mariota's unproven okay they have been a
little unproven at the wide receiver
position as far as go-to targets let
alone they have now a new unproven
offensive coordinator there and arthur
smith to go along with it you got taylor
lawn who's going to be suspended jack
conklin who's coming off injury and has
been underwhelming the last few years so
those all those things added together
makes me a little pessimistic about what
we're going to see from derek henry
especially as compared to how he ended
the year last year on such an amazing
high note
i'm going to stay in the same city that
i started in los angeles i don't believe
the chargers are going to have the
success they had last year for a variety
of reasons earlier in the off season
philip rivers appearing on radio in san
diego said you know what we were 12 and
four we could have gone 16-0 we could
have gone six and ten yeah a lot of
close games those close games are going
to be harder to win now that teams are
looking at the chargers as a measuring
stick franchise and that is a real
dynamic folks other teams will regard
beating the chargers as a bigger notch
in their belt they will feel better
about themselves going forward they're
going to take every game against the
chargers more seriously because the
chargers are closer to the middle of the
nfl's radar screen than they were last
year and i think it's going to be very
difficult for the chargers regardless of
what happens with melvin gordon it's
going to be hard for this team to
replicate what it did last year because
those close games are still going to be
there and those opponents are going to
be coming at them even more aggressively
they've got to play all the teams from
the nfc north which is going to be a
very good division this year i think the
chargers are a team that's going to
backslide the question is do they slide
all the way out of the postseason yeah i
i i hear you mike i mean there's
certainly
certainly you know again just because
you were good last year doesn't mean
you're going to be good this year and
the nfl is so close i mean the
difference between the best team in
football and the 10th best team in
football is like two or three plays
throughout a year that makes a
difference there so uh again i i don't
know if i totally agree with you there i
am still optimistic about them because i
just think there's a lot of talent on
the offense and defensive side of the
football but the teams in their division
have all gotten better too and that's
going to make life harder and the afc is
pretty real
right now in general so i don't totally
hate it i don't know if i love it but i
don't totally hate it
all right what do you got next thing
houston texans i'm going there we talked
about it a little yesterday about you
know that tv it's not the pessimism
isn't odd why that's not a hot take
that's not every everybody's everybody's
looking at the text and saying yeah
they're not going to be able to do it
again this year why who i i haven't
heard one person say that what do we
talk about you just had to disagree with
me just because i threw one little shot
at your pick you just had to come out
firing okay i'm not saying it's wrong to
be pessimistic i'm just saying you're
really not venturing very far out on the
limb with this okay well i don't give a
damn because there's not too many limbs
to venture out on okay i'm not going to
venture on i'm pessimistic about new
england or kansas city and i'm not going
to do it okay
how can you say you're not pessimistic
about tom brady you put him in number
nine on your quarterback rank because
it's a team sport and there's 51 other
good guys on the team okay thank you
very much you could say father tom is
going to catch up with tom brady
not enough to where i'm pessimistic
about it but of the houston texans i'm a
little pessimistic about okay in general
one joe deviant clown he's not going to
be there all training camp two j.j watts
getting older the defensive front seven
was not as dominant in houston last year
whitney merciless didn't have as great a
year we know the offensive line had
issues yes they made improvements we'll
see how that goes i kind of got to see
it first they made some draft picks
they're going to be young can they
contribute i don't know you know will
fuller coming off another acl injury i
mean gosh it doesn't take much the game
plan against the houston texans in that
pass game double cover de'andre hopkins
and force them to see if they actually
will throw the ball to somebody else i
just think with all those things i
expect the jaguars to be better that
division a bit better i'm just a little
pessimistic or bearish on them to where
i think they're on the outside looking
in this year
all right one last pick in today's draft
team or player you're oddly pessimistic
about so far sims has drew brees derek
henry and the houston texans i've got
the two la teams the rams and the
chargers and i'm going to stick with the
team for my last one we talked yesterday
chris about the nfc north and how
smoothed out those four teams really are
how closely packed they may be this year
and how any of those four teams can win
the division or finish in last place or
any spot in between so that makes me
oddly pessimistic about the ability of
chicago bears this year catching no one
by surprise the same dynamic we've
already discussed with the chargers they
will be a measuring stick team they do
not have a history of putting great
years together
and
you know teams will have had a full
off-season to study mitchell trubisky in
the matte naggy offense they lost
defensive coordinator vic fangio that is
a big deal with chuck pagano replacing
him and a new defensive approach i i
think there's a chance this bears team
will not win the division because of
efforts by the packers to get better the
vikings to get better the lions are
lurking and i it makes me pessimistic
about this presumption that the bears
are here to stay simply because they put
together that great season and remember
it ended with the double doink right and
we talked about it with the saints
you've got to reset to zero and zero and
dig out again yeah it's not going to be
the easiest thing to do and if the bears
lose a few games early if they're one
and two or two and four
very different vibe because they're
going to think oh you know it's not a
special year again and that thing can
quickly spiral downward and uh and end
up being eight and eight seven and nine
or something like that yeah i i think
that's fair i mean it's fair especially
like you said in that division with
those teams those quarterbacks i mean
it's scary i mean you know one or two
injuries on your team and you know
you're playing some of those division
rivals and all of a sudden they're
they're the better team because you know
khalil max injured or whatever it may be
so
i i get that totally do you think
they'll still make the playoffs i know
you're pessimistic about them maybe not
winning the division do you think the
bears make it though uh when all said
and done i don't know i'm not going to
i'm not going to say yeah yeah okay i'm
not going to say that all i have to say
is who i'm pessimistic about i'm
pessimistic about the bears winning
division
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports